all rise for the honorable judge ethan
klein
thank you all thank you all welcome to
the court
please you may be seated thank you for
the introduction bailiff
it's been a while since this court has
been in session but it's good to be back
i've got an upgraded wig
and a new bailiff
less attractive but more manly i would
say
in case you get that order here
you know strong arms from the people
right not that ela couldn't do that
let's be honest
um today we have our prosecutor
a.b
looking very sharp thank you your honor
and uh the defendant's uh council would
be zach in his bass pro shop hat
and official
naok boys all right let's pack some
cheese let's smoke some darts
smoke some darts very good
today
uh the defendant is the nelq boyz
nelk you may have heard of is a prank
channel they've been around on youtube
for a while as they've grown in
fame and notoriety they've also grown in
notorious society
notori they've become
infamous yeah there you go for their
antics including
scams straight up
literally being super spreaders of kovid
and just generally being um
a toxic uh you know they say they they
charge plato for corrupting the youth
these guys actually are corrupting the
youth yeah
true it's a vibe right now it is a vibe
so without with that being said let's
get started we're going to start from
the top it's going to get progressively
worse as we go you guys are going to see
and um
well
here we are
the elk boys now they do have a very
strong and loyal fan base so there is a
chance that i will be assassinated in my
home
but i've been you know
i'll protect you thank you
well
while we're here
yeah i guess when you're at home you're
fine yeah you hear that shredder it's
just you yeah so we'll see we'll see but
uh we're gonna give him a fair shake you
know i am a judge i uh
i shall weigh the pros and cons and make
a verdict
as i always do
with that being said oh a quick shout
out this court is made possible by the
spongebob
binge pants podcast
and blender eyewear
thank you to our sponsors and also
just to get the hype going a little bit
teddy fresh has got a pending collab
with this really uh acclaimed japanese
artist
uh yuri sekiya
and uh this is one that i'm really
excited to bring to you guys the art is
phenomenal
and uh the hype train is
derailing
off the rails
go to teddy fresh instagram follow uh
that comes out on the 21st you don't
want the hype train derailing it's just
it's got too much momentum oh you can't
keep it on the track
i see it's it's just because it just
seems like the
hype is dying
perhaps no it derails when there's too
much energy that's when the train
derails instead turn too hard right okay
okay
yeah
by the way i think it was socrates that
corrupted the youth thank you i had a
feeling i got that wrong
one of those guys anyway let's start
this court is now in session
so the elk boys
are a canadian youtube channel and
entertainment company they have 7
million subscribers known for pranks
vlogs
and their brand of full
sending it entertainment
next slide please
so they've got this motto called full
send
uh
you're gonna hear that a lot
and it really encapsulates their
frat boy kind of
i hate to say it but like toxic
masculinity can we say that
can you say that
i mean is it apt is it accurate i think
that's
probably an app description i think
that's what full send means is like
you know
[ __ ] this is not good
so the fault sending it is an action
where the consequences are not thought
through a full sender gives no [ __ ]
what might happen after the send as long
as the send is hype as [ __ ] and the
cameras are rolling
your honor may i give some input as to
what a full sentence could be go ahead
so full send you know it's it's full
force it's whether you're you know
packing some shoes or
smoking a dart or smoking a doobie
slamming a rona what about [ __ ] on
someone's lawn is that right were you
full sending that you're sounding like a
half sender right now a half center is
someone that does not partake in the
action of full sending
yes so can i know sender would that be a
no send yeah no he you have to have
words he's a half center you're not
committed bro oh half center is actually
worse than a no sender because they
didn't fully commit yeah it's like
you're in or you're out [ __ ] yeah right
full cent only for the boys i mean come
on packing shoes smoking darts keep
saying smoking darts what are guards
just to clarify
cigarettes cigarettes smoking darts
right on the board all right square no
surprise that the officer is square as
[ __ ] that's
right um
yeah so full sending would be for
example
you know premeditated murder for example
you say
i am going to kill this guy
and i'm not going to think about going
to jail is that a full send
throwing a little uh decapitation in
there and that's a full song oh [ __ ]
okay right so just a standard
run-of-the-mill murder wouldn't
necessarily portable
could could you do could you perform a
three-quarter send no it's half sanders
dude okay
okay well we'll we'll get more of a uh
grasp of what this means if as we move
forward so please next slide thank you
now cause being charged with offensive
douchebaggery uh public endangerment
and i'd call that a fraud
there's a mug shot of kyle one of the
main protagonists of this story current
and recurring members include salim
kyle jesse lucas steve and bradley
yacked out of his mind juiced up bradley
and i just want to note your honor this
is to the most accurate of my ability
because it's hard to keep track of these
guys yeah i've noticed there's kind of a
rotating door of knock boys yeah but it
did seem like the main protagonist i
mean kyle and jesse
and steve seem to be the main
protagonists of this uh these business
operations is that correct correct
yeah and bradley of course he's he
survives on um
on uh steroids alone actually so he as
long as he's supplied
he's happy he really is a standout isn't
he
all right next slide thank you so much
so the first charge here we're going to
start off and get progressively worse as
i explain but this is offensive douche
baggery
um
just to set the tone and kind of show
you what these guys are all about go
ahead
for a quick introduction to some of
their content here's an example of one
of their pranks
uh here they're shutting down a beach
and forcing a rescue helicopter to show
up because they're fake prank
uh
shark
attack prank man this i watched this
video last night this very this video
sucks man i mean it's only like two
minutes go ahead and play it
what's up guys it's malcolm's here and
today we're in saga beach ontario canada
we're going to try to get people to
believe there's a real shark in the
freshwater lake let's see how it goes
[Music]
get outside
[Music]
and they send a helicopter to rescue
they sent a rescue helicopter out there
so money
why should you guys get the [ __ ] out of
here
that's the whole video
so giving me classic prankster vibes
these are guys that looked up to uh
vitaly and the likes of of him so
their roots are coming from you know
typical
horrible youtube pranksters
and obviously the video is edited to
make it look more i think first of all i
doubt that helicopter showed up for them
one that was my thought as well though
and two the way they edit it to make it
look more epic like that's a whole beach
full of people
um i'm sorry guys i just don't buy it to
begin with and that's why it's two
minutes long
yeah and um
none of the people that were running
really looked scared like they were
laughing they were like laughing and
having a good time yeah like i don't
even know if they were really running
fake prank yeah i think the potential
fake prank yeah
have sending
that's a [ __ ] half sad
and by the way
if you notice if you want to accuse them
of half sending
they bailed fast they made a two minute
video and then they're like ooh the
police are here we better bail that's a
half [ __ ] send my dude that's some
real [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they should have
fought the police think about these half
centers
the police [ __ ] it up man they were
full sending all the way man if they
were full signing they would like fight
the police when they got there no dude
that's
that's that's not a full sentence well
the full scene would be and convincing
the police that they saw a shark instead
of running like [ __ ] no they're full
sending up and down there
you're half sending right now no you're
a half cent in your honor you're half
sending excuses for them hey yo you
don't even pack chews hey
don't don't speak to the judge that way
order
keep it down or you'll be held in
contempt and okay and you'll be charged
with half sending defense i'm done
here is a cringe compilation of uh some
of their previous pranks just to get an
idea of these guys as roots skyhead
please is it actual meat here or no
nothing no meat it's a vegan restaurant
does anyone does anyone want more other
rap this is the gayest place to take a
photo you think oh i don't know i don't
know about gay i would think just a nice
photo would probably be with this one
backdrop no no this looks dance here
you see any good bikes here man just
looking for one for my little sister
little sister yeah
she's like a really hot little sister
too so i want to get her like like a
nice bike you know
you know what i was thinking about one
of them for my girl yeah
oh your little girl yeah
oh sorry
hey don't do that
oh sorry
no i'm just oh
that guy knew what was up
um do you want any black tar heroine
why would i want that i'm just asking
i'm just offering you know no no no are
you sure okay
yeah i'm
sure sorry
yeah
okay i'm just offering
um
just stop doing that
just stop doing that please
oh my god
i get you [ __ ] up
i'm not going to judge him though if we
can't have wine can we get hard stuff uh
bone swings with boneless wings
yeah i mean the boys are all gonna hang
out punch some wings yeah do some hot
yoga you know
[Music]
sorry man
yeah just don't think of a big black
dick in your backswing what kind of
statement is that i'm just saying don't
think of it and uncle steve we're gonna
finish off the [ __ ] wine tour right
now
[Music]
so my problem with their pranks really
is that it revolves around them being
total
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like it's always someone else the butt
of the joke and never them right um and
i feel like good pranks generally
should end like i mean i'm not like the
prank god that makes prank rules but
like
if you're just being a douche you're
just being a douche but like i in my
opinion pranks that i like end up where
people don't want to kill you at the end
of them
right yes that's true you know but even
as far like even under the metrics of of
douche pranks i feel like these i i mean
at least the ones in this compilation
are pretty weak
they should take a lesson
from the gods themselves the bradburys
like the the donut slamming that's a
full sentence that's a full [ __ ]
sentence
yeah yeah like way more than these guys
and these are supposedly the kings of
full sending i don't understand the only
difference between them and the
bradburys is that they just package it a
little nicer and they drink a lot that's
their whole thing right yeah
makes the frat boys get all [ __ ]
invested it's so sweet we're trying to
find the roast of the raw but yeah it's
like eating meat in a vegan restaurant
it's like okay dude um
cool i mean you're just being a dick and
seeing how people react
yeah i think they have a show called
what would you do on uh nbc that already
figured that one out
thank you next slide
the boys have a total disregard for
people they're casually racist sexist
homophobic and transphobic i did notice
some definite homophobic uh
vibes coming out of their pranks already
with the um
every one of the jokes you know
it's just the sus jokes
um and this it's always the guys by the
way with the like oh i'm not gay
i just like a dick in my butt like these
kind of like weird jokes or this is a
gay spot for a photo that are like the
most
um
bi-curious acting dudes like they party
they get naked they like they get super
naked they like touch dicks as a joke
they hot tub together they're not good
and it's like dude you can't kiss your
bro it's okay the year is 20 21. you
know i'm sorry your honor about that the
boys were really half centering there i
think they just had too long of a
hangout with aidan ross so um oh you're
trying to wow so even even zack is
accusing them of a half century that's a
half cent right there those homophobic
remarks are not cool
thank you wilkins thank you yeah exactly
you know they continue to full sign and
you know you'll find out you're honest
okay we'll we'll find out okay but yeah
i mean it's 20 21 dude you guys can
tenderly kiss your bros it's not you can
tuck your bros in good night and give
him a kiss
yeah it's fine it's cool
you are gay
so anyway in this clip they go this is
right as the pandemic is hitting
and people were kind of panic buying
groceries
and they go to the grocery store and
just cause a whole ruckus and then when
someone confronts them
they
basically go on a weird transphobic uh
defense of themselves i'm not quite sure
but go ahead and roll it
oh oh this is mine no
i gotta stock up what you are saying
what are you doing why are you touching
me
but why you are taking that one you can
keep here no we're stuck i'm stocking up
struggling up me look sometimes in life
you gotta take things i need milk man
are you crazy i need milk
that's true the joke is always
like look how pissed off this idiot is
it's like well of course he is
that's the joke you're you're stealing
from it look how much i pissed this dude
off
it's like yeah i mean obviously
it's the prank bro
exactly it's just a prank bro without
that just to prank bro uh language go
ahead then put that back into my cart
i'm gonna need it
yeah show them why i need wine for
tonight i'm sorry there's a whole bunch
of it down there yeah about i kind of
don't want to walk over there and stuff
you know what i mean i don't give a crap
that you don't want to walk over there
how do you figure you can just walk up
to somebody's car to take their stuff
it's like common courtesy you didn't buy
it yeah there's no common courtesy walk
away from me walk away from me now man
do it wow
[Music]
[Music]
you might come back and stab me dude
some people aren't even stocking up
they're just like doing regular shopping
that guy just grabbed two packs
i wasn't talking to you
i was just making a joke well somebody
needs some [ __ ] [ __ ] in their life if
you're targeting me because i'm
transgender that's not very nice okay
you just call me dude some people man
i'm here you're making him feel like a
piece of [ __ ] while he enjoys his turkey
bacon on a [ __ ] whole wheat english
muffin i'm actually a salmon
should we get still even a moan in there
do you think it's funny to make fun of
transgenders because i'm a salmon she
laughs
yeah so
again like their whole shtick is just
being rude and obnoxious as possible to
force people around them to react and
it's not really clever and
they're just [ __ ]
you know
and then it's like oh i'm transphobic
out there i mean the whole shtick is
just
not that [ __ ] interesting i identify
as an attack helicopter
you are a transgender
right
so just to give you an idea of kind of
this we're just laying the groundwork
here
uh here's some of the acts they
associate with on their podcast greats
such as donald trump jr
the epitome of full sending
absolutely
uh jake paul i mean i've had jake paul
on my podcast uh are you is this an
attack on me maybe was this uh before or
after the new york times accused him oh
no mine was way before okay okay
good point
what was the new york times did they
accuse jacob uh what was it uh bailiff
right
yeah i think he was accused yeah that's
what i recall
right and then they had dan blizzarian
on who's you know
if you don't know about manny he's a
piece of [ __ ] tory lanez i i what's he
like shot someone yeah he shot megan the
stallion in the foot last year
that was a full sun moment that was
true that was that was a full song
okay
fair enough fair enough zach jordan
belfort i don't understand why people
are simping for him this guy is like
he's a literal psychopathic criminal
people sim for him he's popular on tick
tock he's a piece of [ __ ] he's the one
that wolf they made the wolf of wall
street about
he's a scumbag he was the good guy in
that movie right
everyone's a good guy
i don't have a problem with what we
don't like about dana white
i hear that he smokes marijuana i smoke
marijuana so i don't beat my wife and
children oh okay
that was dana white's soundbite i didn't
realize
he's actually
just to be fair to dana white he's
quoting somebody else in that no no no
no no no no no
no no okay no context okay got a blaze
dude keep it calm all right go ahead
next that was not that sorry i have sent
that joke right it's a half cent yeah
yeah go ahead and uh next slide please
thank you so much
six nine as you know
is a frequent contributor to the nalca
universe 69 is not a person that any
person should ever want to associate
with
um
for many reasons which will outline but
here's five videos alone 69 reacts to my
music happy endings massage was six nine
okay let's go
jesus
uh six nine i got six nine to make music
again blah blah blah blah blah get up go
ahead play this clip uh please
i wanted to arrange i i i blacked out
and like you hear during the trial i
beat the [ __ ] out of sarah i put my
hands on her i said yo
and the whole time
and god forgive me the whole time i'm
here i'm like yo sarah like
you violated
like you don't do that you don't do that
in the circle like it's like yo yo it's
all in your head okay so so this is big
no no this is huge but let me let me let
me tell you let me tell you exactly how
and then we're gonna get into we gotta
go down
so i'm hitting her she's like damn you
crazy she's crying like then you're
[ __ ] like it's all in your head
you're going crazy you're going crazy
like anyway
here he is basically uh recounting his
tales of heroism where he beat the [ __ ]
out of a woman named sarah
god forgive him uh sarah for hopefully
forgives him it was the she's the mother
of his child and i thought she was
cheating on him even though they weren't
even officially together and she also
denied
fantastic excellent so he's uh he beats
his spouse beats the [ __ ] out of her
also uh 69 pled guilty to charges in
2015 after he used a 13 year old child
and a sexual performance that was
recorded on video and surfaced online
yeah that's that's my you know
my favorite detail about six nine is
that he's basically
a child sex trafficker
is that the right i mean that's
basically what i did probably just
predator i don't know if there was any
trafficking going on to tell you the
truth well she he brought her into the
video where other people probably right
you know yeah
i'm chris hanson with dateline nbc go
ahead and have a seat please six nine
definitely somebody you want to collab
with as often as possible yeah so he's
basically essayed a 13 year old girl i
mean that's that's major league [ __ ]
and then what was there was another
story with the 17 year old right amy uh
yes i believe i was alleged that he had
a relationship with a 17 year old okay
well that i mean first of all
that's a known that's obviously
statutory uh r
but uh
or as dan eloquently put it up
uh but felt like it was
needed that impact for sure
but the 13 year old is is is big leaks
harvey weinstein love i mean epstein
levels yeah anything else
i didn't even think harvey weinstein was
trying to [ __ ] 13 year old girl yeah
over age only yeah he even even harvey
put a line in the sand right
maybe that's how he got in the crew he
was full stunning that's a full sound
that's a full sign pedophile's full send
right zach
nah dude even just saying that that's a
half center moment and you know we told
danny six nine you know he he pulled a
half sending moment other than this [ __ ]
he rat you don't rat never be a snitch
you keep saying we are are you yeah me
and the boys he's the milk boy yeah he's
an elk boy i'm in the i'm standing
behind what don't you understand
so everybody in their audience is
technically part of the crew he's an elk
boy i'm standing behind it's a hive mind
like a jake pauler they all think the
picture of the
gang lined up i'm standing behind
bradley but the dude's like eight feet
tall
[Laughter]
yeah so okay and also he's a notorious
snitch which is a half cent uh but these
are all recent collabs more or less so
like this is all stuff that they're
perfectly happy with associate i mean i
mean it's like doing a collaboration
with r kelly or like o.j simpson at this
point i mean i just it's like hey oj
oj's back at it oj with a knife
anyway next slide full sent that's a
yeah i could see them too
uh don jr isn't the only trump that's
appeared on their channel go ahead
they've made a collab they're trump
simps
now
i don't think there's necessarily
anything
extremely wrong with supporting trump
but the fact that these canadian
prankster frat i don't know the whole
persona really ties together when you
realize they're magga
uh it's very cringe and go ahead and
they're they're canadian yeah they're
canadian right okay canadian trump sims
give you a big fat kiss and watch out
watch how much of beta [ __ ] they turn
into next to the president great to have
you all in air force one look at this
half sending [ __ ] friend of a good
friend of mine that guy right there dana
white somebody like him right he's a
great guy we appreciate it and uh you
really you have a great future
maybe one of you may be flying on it as
president of the united states right
know what you're doing
so good luck good luck thank you it's
amazing okay you guys froze up
yeah they had a major beta moment
dude what a half cent bunch of [ __ ]
they couldn't even muster a word [ __ ]
out of that
he was like giving them a layup too teed
them up for an easy joke rebuttal yeah
one of you will be president yeah it's
like obviously not you know yeah i love
it easy response i mean they're not
american citizens so obviously not right
and also degenerates right that part too
but i think they're theoretically would
not be able to run for president yes so
um
so there you go beta half sentence being
cucked by uh president trump
zach
you know donnie uh i you know i thought
donnie was a full sender but you know
they they didn't have enough like darts
or runners on that plane so
i mean i don't know donald was full
sending i don't want to blame trump no
he's a yeah actually donald trump uh
infamously doesn't drink he says he's
never had a drip alcohol in his house
which doesn't seem very full at all yeah
that's a half sending moment right there
so i think that's why we didn't uh
really blend in with him
um
all right
you were on the plane all right can i
just point out that steve was born in
florida so possibly okay
the og ones are are canadian but steve
is american okay fair enough so here's
one of the previous main
members of nelk
905 the shooter
and he got into a bit of controversy
where he was kicked out of the band 905
was a cameraman featured in multiple
kneel videos who sent unsolicited dick
pics to fans and was removed from the
group afterwards he said and we have the
shot here for everyone to enjoy quote my
balls aren't as big as that potato my
dick is long and thick but not as thick
as the potato either and in a very uh
good now very dry and to the point
analysis
very hot
eight inches long one inch thick i'm a
grower not a shower do you like guys
with big dicks
do you like seeing dicks
if you want you can see mine i'll send
it on snap do you send nudes
uh they i said here's an example of
someone who used to try to shoot with
and message just be careful guys i
cannot stress this enough is that why
they call him shooter because he shoots
and misses every time
it took 905 shots 905 shots yeah like no
no shoddies or anything
yeah so um i'm surprised that they were
troubled by this the the the theory i
heard
is that they were over 905 shooter he
wasn't he wasn't sending he wasn't fully
sending he wasn't hyping up the beasts
and so they dropped the 905 shooter to
bring in steve will do it
yeah kyle uh mentioned many times about
how 905 wasn't doing his job saying that
he's lazy
um
so i think the dick pics were just like
the cherry on top or the excuse they
needed right i mean i can't see these
guys caring about sending dick pics this
seems kind of like oh that seems kind of
like mandatory uh full activity for them
nyno was also the uh the lime
cutter in the house for the ronas so uh
his lime started to get kind of dry so
that's why they kicked them out
interesting well that
that is a crime that actually i'm not
sure how cutting a lime can dry them out
but zach you know more than me
next slide please maybe he was doing
them early and early in the day yeah
instead of like doing them in real time
to try and you know just as a side note
just to prove to you that the neck boys
aren't terrible company they are
defended by none other
than keemstar
who lobbied to bring back 905 shooter
because of course the women are lying
hoes as he says and that seems to be a
consistent narrative throughout keem's
careers that he hates women
i don't know about you guys
but i'm starting to feel a bit sorry
about 905 shooter i hope nelk films
investigates this a bit more if he sent
this video to just this clout chasing
girl then maybe he should get his job
back if the tons of other girls that did
not want his nudes then i don't know
this is the girl that sent 905 shooter
dick pic video
she might be the biggest clout chasing
buffoon i've ever met
she personally asked me four times for
shout out and for ad revenue split on my
tweets i don't even make money from
twitter and i never paid for a story wow
so there you go and it was used in a
book huh
right
that's a tweet keemstar but yeah so just
to understand his logic uh
he
doesn't endorse sending girls unwanted
nudes well unless they're a clout chaser
in which case
he's really
they kind of
have
implied that they're inviting dick pics
to be sent to them if they are looking
to be famous yes yes
and more specifically he doesn't have a
problem with sending
a couple of unwanted dick pics he said
if it's tons of other girls that did not
want nudes so a few is admissible right
team would probably argue just close
your phone
yeah close your phone close your phone
and take three sips of beer three six
take three sips in the morning
i take three sips at night as a
representative of the uh you know
defense counsel the knock boys i just
gotta say keemstar [ __ ] sucks i
really hate him okay that's good
interesting yeah that definitely scores
you some points with the judge he's like
he's super just like he's got napoleon
syndrome you know
okay
dude half god half cent is height
that's for sure you want to anyway let's
not you know it's whatever this is about
game star no here is one of the main
members of nelk uh discussing sleeping
with fans
he says prior to nelk his body count was
one
after now key says he's at about 50 uh
go ahead
what's your body counseling i don't know
i i mean since starting with milk
i mean but before no we do zero before
an elk it was one girl
uh i thought but uh after and then with
milk right i mean we all we did this
tour right we went to florida louisiana
texas
we're everywhere right slamming girls
you know i mean texas was pretty hard i
mean there was a lot of hot blondies
there we'll talk about your body count
yeah nah that shall not be mentioned on
this show
what i'll say is just so i think i got i
think i got you beat
you do
trust me yeah
i got 50 max
you have me beat man you are the [ __ ]
machine no all i'm saying is now you are
the push
bro this guy is no
you made it let's all guess kyle's body
cam
ah that's lie i feel like i mean i don't
i i'm not trying to i don't keep track
of it i i i i'd say a hundred uh i'd say
200. i don't know i'd like yeah a
hundred or so i don't know i mean
i don't know i mean [ __ ] i don't know i
think you know [ __ ] really [ __ ]
he's out here [ __ ] mommy got sweat
look
are you with any uh you like because
obviously when you get the clout you get
more
the [ __ ] comes and that's an ongoing
topic in our show right now
what the [ __ ] i wonder everything
revolves back to [ __ ] here no i mean
we're just obviously we're three no no
because he's like for me where am i i
didn't get any [ __ ] what is this trash
podcast i'm on
i love that both
in both of these clips the guests are
just like uh
i'm not gonna talk about that he's like
listen as you know clout revolving
around to [ __ ] is one of the main
topics here that guy's like what
what y'all would have told me that
uh shaq makes an appearance he makes a
great comment here go ahead
so like i wonder like how it was like
when you were because it's a different
type of funny you know what i mean you
were doing yeah i mean oh
yeah you know
listen man females are out there
respect women be a good guy don't get pj
washington you feel me don't get pj
watched a [ __ ] debate of course you
respect i'm going away what i'm saying
is you pull out the [ __ ] card like
i'm drewski from instagram birds just
recognized drewski bro obviously like
yeah yeah
i heard my good friend gary if he said a
long time ago
he said you know people out there paying
money for these dating apps instagram
and tick tock the best way to meet girls
that's unbelievable
i think girls literally like some girls
like motive when they wake up is to just
like take photos so they can eventually
like bag like a rich guy well yeah like
they're literally just flexing on the
gram and they're just oh my god i'm
talking about the ladies because i i
like my privileges with the ladies well
i hate understanding things
delete me from this conversation
i love shaq and by the way how is he in
everything like when they cut they're
just having this conversation and then
they cut the shack and like of course
shaq is there he's [ __ ] everything i
was waiting for it to go to a new scene
like it had from the previous guy i
didn't realize shaq was actually in he's
just there that's amazing yeah but i
love you delete me from this
conversation which is pretty much the
only proper that was the right response
yeah and you know this is kind of the
telltale sign of just
absolute [ __ ] bag dudes who basically
their whole life and like purpose of
being famous and rich is just
in the pursuit of having sex with as
many girls as possible yeah i know yeah
21 21 savage is basically like my spirit
animal and [ __ ] okay
but anyway yeah trashy dudes are through
and through
here they are
we've caught them looking for a
designer
even their job posts make them sound
douchey
they're looking for a designer
they say please do not apply unless you
don't attach your a portfolio have
designed for streetwear before worked
for past streetwear brands as a designer
are highly skilled
um
our brand is full send you can check out
what kind of designs we run and if you
really want to catch my attention design
something you think we would run
our last
had over 200 applicants and nothing has
impressed me yet
and they're offering 40 000
a [ __ ] year
to 75 to be fair but you know what that
means
they're trying to pay you 40.
which
we should clarify they they are based in
the los angeles area right so well yeah
so i mean obviously i'm in the i'm in
this business and if you're looking for
um
an experienced designer with experience
in like hot one of the top streetwear
brands i mean
they're probably gonna start at at least
75 000. nobody with experience is going
to apply for 75 000 especially by the
way which is the trashiest thing you can
do is ask them to send free work and
custom free work in for the opportunity
to work for you i mean this just reeks
of toxic
employer
um
yeah it's not a surprise that nobody has
impressed you yet because literally
anybody with any talent or experience
would
run far away from this post he has no
pizza experience right
here's a great moment of nelka leaking
mike tyson's phone number on twitch
fantastic
[Laughter]
all right we good
oh [ __ ] they're just gonna absolutely
faded by tyson
and it was on there for a good like 10
seconds the [ __ ] is going on
this is the second time it was on screen
they did it twice yeah that's why mike
kept getting interrupted during the call
oh he's like who keeps calling you [ __ ]
he tells him hang up you're talking to
them playing it it's great
[ __ ] me
we might have uh
we might be getting a beat down from
tyson
after what we just did
[ __ ]
it's a lot of people that it's not going
to be happy
oh no
[ __ ]
start off with a little crap does roy
joins [ __ ] with us too or not fantastic
thank you because now we're yeah his uh
hat says thank you for [ __ ] with us
you're welcome
thank you
uh-oh go ahead so in closing again we're
starting off light from here it's going
to get pretty wild
but obviously in the case of excessive
douchebaggery
frat boy toxic masculinity the
embodiment of everything you hate about
men
basically uh guilty guilty guilty
anything you guys want to add to that
i think it speaks for itself
unless uh the representative or
defense wants to say anything
just delete me from this conversation
right
good call
all right moving on actually uh we
should uh throw to a quick okay let's do
a break and moving on to the next
section which we'll do a little tease
here
is
do a little tease here a little bit of a
teaser
i said you were talking to me i'm sorry
yeah
uh public endangerment now these guys
were basically super spreading
everywhere
during the during the pandemic and of
course someone in their audience even
has a free bill cosby sign so you don't
see that everywhere
you notice that at the top right i did
not notice that yeah
well if you're gonna spread corona you
wanna you want it to be you wanna full
send like you wanna spread it to as many
people as you possibly can and i think
cosby's gonna i mean people in jail were
catching it no problem right
that's true that dude was just like a
fat albert fan so he just wanted to show
free that man i think it's more about
them wanting to go to hell it's the
final scent the ultimate full sun
take our souls that's good i'll see you
there
all right let's thank our sponsors and
we'll be right back
all right thank you to spongebob binge
pants a new podcast
coming officially from nickelodeon take
a deep dive down to bikini bottom with
this official spongebob squarepants
companion podcast hosted by frankie
grande
and hector navarro
this is henry danger and nickelodeon's
animation podcast studio are going to be
doing this
because they love spongebob squarepants
and that's why they decided to rewatch
the entire series starting all the way
back to the iconic first episode each
week frankie and hector are going to be
having hilarious conversations and
interviews with special guests from
voice actors to veteran artists
uncovering behind the scenes secrets
about what's everybody's favorite sp sea
sponge
spongebob binge pants is a weekly
celebration of all things
absorbent and yellow and porous
we love that they um let's see this is
nickelodeon's official companion podcast
to spongebob this is the best show ever
made and it's time it gets its own
podcast people
spongebob is a insanely prolific show
top tier
like and it just its influence on
popular culture is pretty unmatched the
longevity i mean i watched it when i was
a kid it's kind of like the shakespeare
of uh kids cartoons in a sense
because like how much they've influenced
pop culture you know
the memes the memes my friends drew
so yeah you if you want to relive every
episode of spongebob and learn about all
the spongebob universe this is the
podcast for you episodes are going to be
out every thursday and it's going to be
available on a
podcast all podcast platforms
so listen to spongebob binge pants on
the iheartradio app
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast thank you
thank you to spongebob binge pants good
luck i hope luis you guys lots of
success on the podcast
thank you thank you to blender's eyewear
fresh from san diego california comes
the only sunglass brand i'm ever gonna
wear again because blenders eyewear
is just got me hooked with these awesome
shades
um here's the styles that you can expect
from their website these look sick i
actually like that green color
[Music]
uh the prices are fantastic the styles
are slamming i like that green one
though too
there's so many styles
i definitely recommend checking it out
there's so many options for men women
they have snow goggles they have name
brands too sales
[ __ ]
blenders eyewear.com
uh chase fisher started blenders by
selling his beachy shades out of a
backpack while doubling as a surf
instructor on the pacific beach his goal
to create an adventurous mid-priced
eyewear option with the same cool factor
as other leading styles and unlike other
expensive big brand shades that you've
probably lost or smashed in the past
blenders are actually affordable so
you're not going to cry
as much when the inevitable happens
let's be honest
you know blender's team of in-house
designers are constantly coming out with
new styles from orange polarized
wrap-arounds tortoise shell frames with
purple lenses to classic gold arms
on black lens and it's not just about
sunglasses blenders also as prescription
glasses readers with blue lights as well
as a snow collection with goggles and
accessories
live life in forward motion with
blenders today and for our listeners you
can score 15 off your blender's purchase
visit blenderseyeware.com
and enter the promo code h3vip
one word there
uh that's blenderseyeware.com
code h3vip for 15
off blenders rocked with pride worldwide
welcome back everybody uh moving on to
the second charge as we touched on
public endangerment so let's get right
into it
um
so now boys are known for actively
encouraging people to ignore covet
safety not just encouraging but like
actively participating
in
the flaunting of kovid's safety
guidelines and and laws frankly
youtube demonetized their whole channel
for actively encouraging people to
ignore covet safety
during the height of the pandemic around
september 2020
that's freaking epic man yeah i knew
their channel got demonetized but i
didn't realize uh that it was for that
there could be so many other reasons
there were multiple different protests
created and led by the elk boys in
various parts of the country in los
angeles they hosted a open up the gym
protest
it was a story heavily covered in the
media
uh taylor lawrence new york times
reporter tweeted youtubers knows nilk
boys after hosting an open gym open up
gyms protests and partying their way
through la are now traveling to colleges
encouraging students to ignore coveted
restrictions to party
please take off your mask
um here is some of the examples of them
touring
uh college campuses during kovit go
ahead this is hot by the way just for
just for context this is pre-vaccine
fight of the pandemic
uh a total [ __ ] show go ahead
[Applause]
illinois is not good
a heavily blue state too right
uh illinois yeah generally yes so there
they are corrupting the youth in action
go ahead
no
yeah go ahead you hit pause i've i've
been to a lot of parties even ones that
uh one might call a rager
and none of them was the party aspect
just a giant crowd of people just
screaming at the top of their lungs
continuously jumping up and down and
well you've never full sended myself i
guess not i mean i thought i'd partied
pretty hard in my days but i you know
usually like music and like dancing and
like you know well i think what they're
doing here which is especially uh
insidious is that they're basically
going on a covid uh campus party tour
right right and then well what's
fantastic here
is that after this particular event
the president of the school
was forced to give a speech
condemning the the uh
events go ahead
reportedly gathered around the elk boys
at a local apartment complex in the
early morning hours
and the normal police arrived and the
crowd dispersed
it really gives me no joy to convey
my great disappointment in the actions
of those who gathered
indeed the bulk of our students here are
doing what we expect them to do
i kind of wish it was
in the middle of classes here you'd see
a lot of students walking around here
with their masks on socially distanced
and doing the right thing unfortunately
some of those last night last night did
not
so
we're investigating that if any
individuals are identified out of out of
that
that gathering
we have a student conduct code that will
be applied the mayor and i are talking
about you know other potential sanctions
that the town of normal might
issue as well but i was very
disappointed very saddened and uh
we hope that that never happens again
here but the bulk of our students are
doing the right now go ahead now
remember what we said about full sending
right
we don't think of the consequences well
in this case go ahead to the next slide
they were able to identify
[Music]
[Applause]
they were able to identify
100 students
who all faced
disciplinary consequences which includes
up to being
um
expelled from the school
your honor if i may interject i think we
uh me and the boys missed the memo
we heard corona
so we were
we thought that was what we were going
you thought it was a corona party yeah
they when elk said corona party yeah you
thought they meant corona
season for the boys if i may interject i
think you guys fully sent the future of
these students straight to hell
with their souls
dude rona does that to you you know you
get hung and you know you got to puke it
out but you got you just got to
appreciate that uh all these dudes came
to party at the request of nelk and
possibly
um
ruined their
college aspirations they were kicked out
of school and you can only imagine the
fallout of that i bet the milk boys felt
really bad about that yeah they felt so
bad they moved on to the next school and
did it we thought catching a case of
rona was actually catching a 12-pack of
carom
and then when you're like well when
you're like well 77 people you know may
have died as a result of that gathering
you say well yeah you know at milk
parties people often do over drink and
die of alcohol poisoning a couple of
half sanders yeah so i was hoping i
would find a video of one of them on a
car like [ __ ] your parents or
death to all your grandparents because
they definitely took out some sort of
people in that town with that party yeah
right that would be a full send if they
could kill someone's grandparents yeah
that'd be epic as [ __ ] dude
so uh i'm gonna go rip a dart
oh he actually says that
for sure go ahead is it rona season
go ahead the next slide please
here's the now boys once again throwing
a massive protest in the middle of the
streets in la during the height of the
pandemic once again
they
are part of the open up the gym movement
which they consider an essential service
like eating
you know
[Applause]
this is pure degeneracy dude
love it
[Applause]
i'd like to thank you guys for coming
out i'm glad to see all the tank tops
that i do see
so epic antics as you can see
free merch
free argument with that bad at merch
actually i do want to touch on their
merch zach is wearing one of their
jackets
that cost 200 bucks i want to show it to
you guys
but uh he's a beast as you can see now
they're gonna be heading
down to the gym
ripping those sleeves off no sleeves no
sleeves i'll send
he's scaling the wall of the gem
full centers right there
uh this is when you see free bill cosby
i actually saw it already in one of the
scenes
he's rocking that sign it's uh we muted
it because there's uh
there's music in it
anyway um
yeah it's just pure degeneracy as you
can tell
yeah
so if you if you can
if you can go um
to the next slide where they're
juiced up homies crying about gym lives
matter
yeah so this is um a member of nelk
bradley martin
uh
and aren't crying that he needs to keep
gyms open here's a video uh let's see
during this again during the peak of the
pandemic despite city health guidelines
and having their power even turned off
by the city at times
and uh interestingly enough it's like
they want the gym open but they also
refuse to
observe safety protocols like you know
wearing a mask basic [ __ ] like that
and they try to spin himself as
basically the martin luther king of
keeping the gym open
so it's the great struggle of our time
yeah
so go ahead
the gym open the reason why it's so
important to me and there's so many
people who come here every single day
drive hour and a half drive half an hour
drive two hours because it's the only
gym open right now
is for physical and for mental health
it's not for another person another
human being to decide what's essential
for you you know when you see like
celebrities and like these famous people
they like they od or they suit they they
kill themselves and you see everyone
like oh
suicide prevention hotline number and
all these things and everyone talks how
mental health is such a serious problem
and it's a serious issue we need to
address it more we need to talk about it
more
yet
during a pandemic someone could tell you
that
food is essential absolutely air is
essential water's essential there's
certain essentials that we need medical
stuff we need right yes but how can
someone determine what's essential for
you and your mental health okay
i have a heart so as you know i don't
understand yeah so water
shelter reasonable air yeah absolutely
food
gym
right that's right
that shoes darts you know keeps keeps
the spirits what i don't understand is
if they want if they're trying to do
like the right thing here just wear
masks then and like social distance in
the gym well then you can at least have
some moral ground to stand on no at some
point in la the gyms were like fully
fully closed right yeah so i mean it may
have been during that
but yes i'm assuming it was well when
they were fully closed we were fully
sending my dude so
you got it thank you um
yeah i just uh
i i don't think that the point he's
trying to make is totally absurd you
know i think exercise is important for
mental health and everything um
but
you
can exercise without a gym listen the
point is that we all [ __ ] sacrifice
right this is your hobby right we all
make sacrifices during the pandemic for
the great the greater good he's being a
selfish baby and trying to make the gym
seem essential as [ __ ] breathing
right we all can't go i had to [ __ ]
work move my whole setup into my [ __ ]
basement even though we could continue
to do it because we were in a carved out
exemption of production
you know we didn't leave the [ __ ]
house we didn't have help at the house
we all make [ __ ] sacrifices for the
greater good but he's being too much of
a [ __ ] baby it's like dude you can't
do some workouts at home for like a
month you know what i'm saying uh or but
but again if they would just do the
proper protocol safety protocols then i
would maybe agree with what you're
saying dan a little more but if you're
trying to make a point
then like why not wear a mask in social
distance it just you don't [ __ ] care
and also look at your you're part of now
of course you don't care about the
pandemic like what the [ __ ] is he even
talking about he literally doesn't care
about the pandemic at all
yeah there's no so he's just being a
baby and and so he owns this gym is that
right
that is my understanding right so i mean
he has a financial interest
yeah he's trying to make it about mental
health and even if he has a little bit
of a point on the mental health thing
obviously it's about him losing money
yeah dude everyone's mental health was
[ __ ] during the pandemic like talk to
a therapist bro i don't know what to
tell you go do some push-ups in your
bedroom i don't know bro [ __ ] get some
weights and go just charge
you know right [ __ ] that's the thing i
yeah that that's where the argument
falls apart i bet this guy took a pp
loan too almost certainly
to help pay for his dumb ass gym that
stayed open right
but this just but again this the if the
city was forced to shut off his
electricity
it was that serious or dire of a
situation now let me remind you all the
kovid has passed the spanish flu
for global fatalities oops
okay
we're approaching a million deaths now
and at the time the death rate was like
astronomical
uh
it was everything in the word
five percent far beyond five percent
yeah
so um
yeah go ahead you could keep playing it
though he starts
again i sympathize i guess but like we
all make sacrifices bro you don't care
about the pandemic it's obvious and the
reasoning behind this one when it's a
problem and everyone talks about mental
health and suicide prevention and how
serious of an issue it is
it's taking people's lives because
people need an outlet somehow he's just
talking about his body
gaming cafes anyone's hobbies now
essential uh driving range that's
probably fine because it's outdoors but
i'm just saying laser tag bro i [ __ ]
with laser tag dude it's essential to my
mental health it's your hobby i mean
come on man
yeah it's not
the argument falls apart pretty quick i
mean exercise again i mean that one it
makes more sense to me than than gaming
then go take a jog
that exactly he's talking about getting
exercise he's not talking about
exercising you can exercise
anywhere yeah
right he doesn't he doesn't want to lose
his gains
yeah
which are all natty as [ __ ] for sure
yeah
you can take steroids in the privacy of
your own home bro
yeah that was a full scent in the main
vein he's you know his face is juicing
up
but then it's equivalent to being like
you know
uh
indoor soccer i don't know i gotta
exercise bro
yeah it's just it's stupid
you want to keep going on this yeah dean
right because that's their outlet right
it's not the best outlet it's leading
them to that path for the person who is
ending their life because they can't
find a different outlet right so i just
don't get it when someone could say yeah
that's super super important mental
health is super important but right now
during a pandemic it's not important
anymore that's not what anybody said
people just said you got to [ __ ] lose
you got to close your gym bro because
it's a high risk activity everyone's
sandwiched into a tight space breathing
heavy what's not the hard to understand
about that dude
anyway he starts crying at one moment go
ahead you realize how important this is
for some people and you wouldn't know
unless you realized it for yourself how
much it means to some people how much it
meant to me how much it saved my life
when i was younger so
just like four weeks man
it's not up to another human to decide
what's essential for your mental health
and that's the thing that i'm drawing
the line here and that's why i'm
fighting back right we're just supposed
to all say do steroids make you unstable
emotionally they cause mood swings yeah
i believe yes that's what i was kind of
watching i'm just spitting facts you
know yeah
the vaccine is ready so a company can
make billions and billions and billions
of billions of dollars okay so we just
all hide and like we should just wait
for that and use tons of hand sanitizer
and hide and hide and hide and hide and
then come outside and get [ __ ] sick
and die the [ __ ] flu like but it's
just it doesn't add up it's like telling
like oh that person has a mental illness
you should go see that therapist that
therapist i know they're good you need
to talk to them what if that person
doesn't jive well with that person what
if that what's your mental illness
exactly
at all
maybe they don't need to talk directly
to someone so he's saying the gym is his
is his therapist but right
once again which is
i mean it's not it's true that's true of
any hobby right exactly i mean exercise
in particular is
but he's not like [ __ ] exercising
he's get i mean he is but like it's not
exercise like taking a run he's getting
yeah right it's his hobby
this is
extreme weightlifting we weren't banned
from working out in general you go
outside do it in your house anyway
whatever but the whole pretense that he
cares about covet is laughable
considering he just had
a whole coved protest outside his gym
thank you thank you
right
um
oh so apparently he was even sued by the
state of california
for his gym remaining open zoo culture
the people of the state of california
versus zoo culture welcome to 2020 where
jim's being open is criminal in
california where mental and physical
health is deemed non-essential again
mental and physical health
is done not exclusive to
getting the act in a gym yeah exactly
there's a video beautiful
that's awesome
surprise dude there's consequences i
mean what do you want and and and
you know
it's a pandemic [ __ ] a million people
almost dead just in the united states
alone like 700 over 700 000 just in our
country
you got to make a sacrifice don't be a
[ __ ] baby
thank you
uh they did a fan meet up all over the
country including one at the jersey
shore's house where an estimated 2 000
people showed up masculists ready to
party during the height of the pandemic
i see it now the house made famous by
jersey shore i guess and if you ask
enough they'll say partying is essential
who's to decide that partying is an
essentially good for my mental health
yeah exactly specifically the kind of
partying where i just stand there and
jump up and down screaming scream into
each other's face unmasked faces
yeah go ahead uh this one's gone
covered by inside edition so because
it's the site of a potential super
spreader of covet 19 thousands of
partiers making no attempt to socially
distant and most of them not wearing
masks all packed together at a party
that was organized by a group of youtube
pranksters they call themselves the
knelt boys then as les drent reports the
cops showed up
a massive crowd gathered outside the
notorious beach house made famous on the
reality tv show jersey shore hello let's
drink
[Music]
forget about masks and social distancing
now there are fears it could turn into a
pandemic super spreader event the
multitude was drawn to the house by this
video posted on social media by the
popular youtube personalities the knelt
boys
things got out of control pretty quickly
[Applause]
the nuff boys have been under fire for
throwing huge parties at college
campuses across the usa in defiance of
the ongoing pandemic last night on the
jersey shore the nelk boys were ordered
to leave the house are you actually
getting kicked out
it's time to go i spoke with cece hearts
mayor anthony vaughan in the [ __ ]
mansion what happened here yesterday
very very annoyed frustrated at the
owner
because he was told several days in
advance that this possibly can happen
the six bedroom house is available
online to rent by the night at the cost
of two thousand six hundred dollars
today i caught up with the home's owner
immediately after he left a meeting with
city hall officials do you regret that
it happened in your place
hell yeah i regret this happening i am
responsible it's it is my fault it's so
[ __ ] it sounds like
yeah so spreading uh peace and love uh
everywhere
absolutely and there's no greater peace
and love than being reunited with god
which they probably uh reunited many
grandparents with their
i mean i'm thinking about suing them too
it used to be gtl now it's gtd just gym
tan death
gym tan
death what was gtd
no gtl
laundry
gym tan death laundry was one of their
laundry yeah
country is important i guess
gotta keep it clean dude yeah
interesting
once again in all of these videos i mean
i just
these parties look like they [ __ ]
suck dude
it's just a bunch of people screaming
that's a rager bro it's not a rager i've
been to rachel why are you hating dude
once upon a time i'm sorry that that
party looks like why are you mark the
party is not a full set bro
i don't know why you're more interested
in the quality of the party
because at least at least
if you're going to have a coveted super
spreader party at least
dan's the type of dude to define a party
by how many foosball tables there are
foosball that's what i'm just saying i
don't know what you
you everybody is
if it's a party that's going to kill you
let it be a party to die for like at
least have some like music maybe like
this is literally just a crowd of people
jumping up and down can you put on
astroworld
[Laughter]
proof that you've been debunked yeah
all right next slide thank you dan
other examples of nelk being a menace to
society here's the numerous times
they've been arrested now boys kyle
discovered he's wanted by the police in
a drunk driving prank
fantastic
nell gets arrested for target prank
fantastic are they all lined up by the
police kyle
youtuber busted for allegedly
impersonating an officer fantastic
they were also arrested for
impersonating a toys r us employ and
shooting nerf guns at shoppers you know
it's a good idea to [ __ ] around
where kids shop
uh arrest warrant for driving around
pretending to drink beer arrest for
impersonating a target employee and
harassing customers arrested for
impersonating a security guard and
harassing customers we love that for
them don't we well the one thing i'm
confused about these these guys are
canadian i don't know how you can get
arrested so many times and not be
deported i genuinely don't get it like
you're clearly a menace to society isn't
there laws that say like if you're here
on a visa and you [ __ ] around you get
deported i'm confused by that
i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta do the uh
full send claws they can't send you back
they got judges in their pocket yeah
well yeah that's why we went on a
trump's plan you know
yeah
i guess when you're friends with the
prez you can we got immunity dude we'll
send it up boy yeah i mean dana white
just texts trump and be like yo take
care of the full send boys
you know canada is not sending their
best that's what i hear
you people are worried about mexico
sending predators look at canada man we
got to shut down the border on canada
yeah
like empty the jails you know what i
mean right build a wall on canada man
this [ __ ] is out of control yeah i heard
their homies with trudeau you know it's
pretty tight how many canadians has ice
deported
that's what i want to know yeah let's
get those canadian numbers up
start time to policing the northern
border
go ahead that's uh so in closing it's
clear to me your honorable judge
that these these guys have a
absolutely
uh
heinous disregard for public safety and
even
let's be frank the welfare of their fans
uh
even resulting in like 100 people being
expelled from college as a result
of their antics
they are just
horrible people they just don't care
about anything
bullseye bro
zack you want to defend them on that one
i mean
you know we're
party animals dude
by the way let me see your jacket so
zack used to be a full scent fan his
friend bought him this jacket
he claims his friend bought him this
go ahead a
throw it down in gift
of the judge i'll fully go ahead
audience all right i'll pick it up
zach's about to listen to you so this is
so what's interesting
yeah so this is a full send jacket it
was 200
there's one print there and then on the
front thank you zach if you could show
the print there but what's interesting
to me is that show the dickies this is
just a dickies jacket
it even had they never it even still has
the tag on it
this isn't an official collaborating
thing they literally just bought
dickie jackets and hit them with prints
and sold them for 200 bucks so you know
200 you know what abe you're not cool
enough to wear this merch bro could
someone tell me how much is the retail
on a dickies
jacket just like a normal dickies jacket
yeah i'm curious dickies
jacket
that's a full sand my dudes uh this
looks pretty similar it's 50 bucks yeah
so it's a that's a healthy markup
actually
yeah they're like let's put a logo on
the back and zach's like
i mean i mean
i'll take two
and it's just a basic prince i mean that
probably costs like two bucks on them
to print you know you know what you're
out of the [ __ ] party dude maybe i'm
happy nobody wants to go that [ __ ]
party dude
you're out
full send my ass away off of my mouth
daddy that's the part that's the parties
they have you're not cool enough for
that a b
i guess not there did the hat come with
it
they got a brass uh
pro club a brass pro bass pro a
bronzer's pro club
all right moving on thank you thank you
thank you uh
plaintiff
did you hit the hammer did we thank you
so and my
honorable judgment they are of course
guilty
gift [ __ ]
no question no question
these guys are now this is when it gets
so bad
that it's base i think there's criminal
uh well the bat the last one was
criminal let's be honest but this one
can really uh result in some serious
jail time for the milk boys like no
shotties or anything no shoddy's in jail
uh third charge a jaw rule you want to
introduce this one
uh yes let me call john rule gile do you
have a statement you like to make i
would call that uh fraud thank you right
so
this of course involves
gambling giveaway sites and just a lot
of really shady stuff that we're gonna
get into detail with it's really good go
back please
um here's a tweet from steve i was down
65k in the casino i went upstairs and
fired a 50k bet in bitcoin on an online
casino then i then i did 15k lost it
then 30k won it i mean the moral story
is you only losing gambling if you quit
go to war with the casino
sage advice 39 million shares of safe
moon
that's basically a sure-fire way to um
ruin your life
moon's going to the moon baby absolutely
oh boy all right next slide please thank
you
so the knock boy's first foray into
scamming was a potential ferrari
giveaway scam they teamed up with a
company called whizza to give away a
ferrari to one lucky random fan who
enters a raffle and the raffles cost
five bucks that was the minimum
purchased for a hundred entries so
basically that's one you get five bucks
you get an entry wizard now wiza
i don't know if i'm getting ahead of
myself here but
where's uh what's different about wiza
and other
websites is that it's owned by
their best body
whizzes owned by their best body and as
you'll see their raffles are beyond
questionable
statistically i would say that this is
uh has to be fraud go ahead and play
the video classic red ferrari the
baddest ferrari that you can [ __ ] get
three hundred fifty thousand dollars a
little baggy container boom it's pretty
[ __ ] insane we're teaming up with our
really really good friends at wizza
they're our boys and we're going to be
giving away one [ __ ] crazy ass item
every single month so this month it's a
[ __ ] full center that's crazy that's
a pretty fast drop you can enter that's
as you want the more you buy the more
chances you have to win we're going to
announce the winner in one month and
we're actually going to be pulling up to
the winner's house and delivering
ferrari personally
that's probably
during the pandemic right now and we're
going to be
completely changing someone's life that
is the portion of the proceeds so that's
something we're going to film as well
we're going to do everything every month
and this is the first year we're giving
away with wizards so so anyway deposits
how crazy so they're they're running a
scheme with this company wiza and
basically you buy raffles to win the
ferrari
but it's just straight cash they're just
giving cash straight up for nothing
essentially these these virtual tickets
but what if i told you that it's pretty
much been proven that this ferrari was
never given away in fact
it was uh never intended to be given
away that would literally just be them
collecting money
straight up that's wrong that is
straight up fraud
uh there's been a lot of great
investigating which i'll give a shout
out to there are multiple factors that
make the giveaway extremely suspicious
first of all the winner
now you can enter these guys have a lot
of fans all across the united states and
the world
the winner of this
bought one ticket and happened to live
in adelaide a convenient
three minutes
away from the elk boys oh my god
i won a car despite it being a worldwide
now a worldwide competition with
literally thousands of tickets being
bought tens thousands hundreds of
thousands i don't know
um
let's go ahead first of all
there's a few really interesting uh
aspects here someone even found that the
car was parked three minutes away from
the winter's apartment a month before
any winner was ever drawn now we're
gonna watch the first video here
presented by as you can see um his name
is jamari i believe
is that right as it was written before
yeah so jamari i actually like his
channel he's pretty he's pretty good i
like his videos check him out jamari did
an excellent video on it we're going to
watch an excerpt right here go ahead
here the winner was supposed to be drawn
on june 14th that was the guy who
eventually had won this ferrari but see
they got caught slipping a little bit
when this uh random twitter user was
just uh chilling in her apartment and
she happened to see this full send
ferrari parked downstairs in the garage
this was on may 6th a month before the
winner was apparently drawn and just to
prove this is a legitimate tweet from
may 5th uh here's like an accompanying
tweet that went with it she talks about
she saw the ferrari in her apartment
complex and then here's just the actual
tweet i was showing you guys um this is
obviously the exact same ferrari you
have the wizard sticker right there and
on the back they even have a wizard
license plate so it's like okay well
maybe they were just parking that
ferrari in some sort of la garage right
nothing too sketchy about that well the
video goes on
and uh man these people are doing some
fbi level investigation so they're
looking at the picture broadway palace
apartment that's where it was parked
that's where this girl was living
broadway palace apartment
and then there they are at the actual
giveaway that's a screenshot from when
they went over to the guy's apartment
where they had to take this car and
that's an apartment called the met lofts
keep in mind all these apartments are in
downtown los angeles so uh let's see how
far are the met lofts from the other
broadway apartments wow three minutes
down the road
a month ago now statistically speaking
for one guy
to win this ferrari in a worldwide even
nationwide competition for the ferrari
to be stationed three minutes away from
his house has got to be you know in the
in the magnitude of of billions
so arrest so unlikely
that um
you'd have to be a [ __ ] such
a
dumb stan to not think that this is a
total scam
i mean it's just disgusting they're
criminals and they're dumb criminals at
it this is just horrifically dumb
scamming right here my friends go ahead
this ferrari just happened to be parked
three minutes down the road from the
eventual winner it's impossible that
seems a little suspect right guys
i'm not trying to draw any absolute
conclusion here but just in my opinion i
would never enter one of these giveaways
again to me it seemed like some very
thick [ __ ] and it's just
not like oh don't enter the giveaways
this is like this is [ __ ] theft
people donated straight up gave them
money
there was no exchange of goods just
giving them money
this is so [ __ ] illegal this is
straight up fraud like someone should be
going to jail for this
guys
yeah i mean i i don't know how we're
going to do that ja rule
uh i'm just assuming my only assumption
is that there's so much crime going on
on youtube right now that the fbi is
just backlogged as [ __ ] like how do you
keep up with all this [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
true
you must just be some blinded fanboy who
would do anything for these full send
[ __ ] i remember on my last
video someone left a comment like oh you
seem like a half sender you're just
jealous oh yeah i'm totally jealous of
the dudes who are entering their near
30s still acting like 18 year old frat
boy douchebags who can't give up the
college life
thank you thank you uh jomari you do
sound like a half center no but i'm real
i do like uh jamari's videos are i like
him i'm a fan go check him out
um so here is another
uh
powerful clue where go ahead and play
this is when they give out the ferrari
nice to meet you bro here's the key how
many tickets did you buy dude i just
bought one bro
yeah so he just bought one ticket and
combined with the everything else it's
like
i think i think what they were trying to
do is like encourage people to enter
right but again they're so dumb they're
such dumb criminals that is the
shittiest acting too are you saying that
this guy
could be
could be
a criminal this face
this
yeah i'm not commenting i mean yeah yes
go ahead uh you if you want to analyze
the acting could be my guess
it's like well it came with like a
hundred or something right you want you
bought like a hundred dollars worth of
dollars one yeah
five five dollars the minimum
[Music]
what was like what did you expect when
you entered like i thought this whole
show was a scam
[Music]
just laying it all out there hey
[ __ ]
in reality you guys got scammed oh my
god guys real deal man this is my whip
yeah
yeah let's go check it out
that's crazy i guess
i think it just seems like a scam
because it's too it's it's too epic yeah
it's too good to be true but it is true
what are you guys
saying we're on camera right now
it's beyond a comprehension that you
could be this dumb
why would they even talk about it being
a scam like even if it was real right
why would you come and start talking
about oh everyone thought it was a scam
it's not that hard to believe that
people sending you free money if people
do a million dollars in tickets and you
spend 300 000 on a car it makes perfect
[ __ ] sense i mean it's not crazy it's
just the lottery yeah it's literally
just a lottery scam like
yeah no it's not um
so fbi
fbi on twitter
yeah fantastic so this this is the first
chapter
yeah because they don't get caught you
know they get so comfortable
it's hard to believe but
whizza their friends who ran the scam
um their other partners steve will do it
the milk boy is right up there front and
center along with such reputable figures
as aiden ross
faze blanks with a monkey what are you
michael jackson
what the [ __ ] he doing with the monkey
come over here bubbles i don't know why
that didn't register for me before yeah
he's just chilling with the monkey
oh that's actually an ape
just a small clarification how's that an
ape because it's a chimpanzee it's not a
monkey it's an eight okay
i also wanted to point out that
initially there were other members of
nelk on the partner page that have since
been removed but not steve will do it
he's sticking around
yeah i was on there and i don't know why
they took me off but they took you off
yeah so they they dropped you not the
other way around yeah interesting zach's
getting indicted it was it was been a
good time but you know just bad vibes
half sanders yeah wait but they dropped
you
okay let's not get let's not get too
wrapped up in the
story faze blanks ricegum and mike
magelick mike
i keep i'm sorry if i say his name right
matt matt
magillick i think that was right okay
the thing about mike that is it
surprises me is that his whole shtick is
about
being a an advocate for addiction
and stuff he wrote a whole book about it
but he shills gambling which is one of
the most deadly destructive addictions
you can do so it's like you clearly
don't give a [ __ ] about anything but
making money you hypocrite piece of [ __ ]
scum [ __ ] you mike majlik
also faze banks is he goes when was
talking to him in the dms because we
were trying to like bury the hatch or
whatever
and he goes why don't you like me and
it's like because of [ __ ] like this you
are at the center of every shady
activity on the internet bro cs go lotto
you owned it [ __ ] whizza you're
involved all the crypto [ __ ] you're
involved you're at the center of
everything bro you [ __ ] are a scammer
i'm sorry and you own a monkey freak
h3h3 humor
it just makes me pissed off like dude if
you don't want me to hate you if you
care about my opinion so much just don't
be a piece of [ __ ] scammer who [ __ ]
your fans as a lying piece of [ __ ]
scumbag who would rather make money than
anything else douche
summer rae i don't know who she is but
and then aiden ross's girlfriend too
it's in the family keep it in the family
yeah uh with peace and love of course
phase
i don't know what to tell you i mean on
a personal level you're fine but like
every time i look you're involved in
another scheme that's just shady as [ __ ]
so yeah he's [ __ ] stupid
i'm sorry bro
i wanna i want to like squash the beef
with banks but it's like every time it's
like dude what the [ __ ]
i can't stop [ __ ] on you when you
keep doing shitty things
but mike magic most of all shame on you
you hypocrite [ __ ]
[ __ ] that guy's dumb shit's his gym
shorts
anyway
peace and love
here's a steve from now
discussing his pur close personal
relationship with the owner of wizzah he
describes him as one of his best friends
and how he's gifting him a richard
milley watch as a thank you that's a 300
000 plus
watch
um
so this is kind of the proof in the
pudding that the owner of wizard who did
the fake giveaway of the ferrari and him
our
best friends essentially go ahead
but this wizard [ __ ]
my two best friends own it bro
and they've helped they've helped me
make millions wow i mean
and again all my money is not from
selling marriage
and again it's like these guys are too
dumb to even be slick criminals they
give the game away
at every [ __ ] turn
you're not supposed to admit that the
guys that owned the scam you're shelling
shilling are your best friends
but go ahead he does it he does it for
us i [ __ ] have figured out
other ways to make it yeah scanning
people
200 000 spurs badass i can't i don't do
that i'm selling t-shirts
it's actually impossible okay
so scanning i figured out like i've like
i've gotten financial advice scam
this and that for my two buddies they've
helped who are scammers so it's like
they own wizards
they've helped me make so much money to
wear
to wear it
i don't even want anything
oh yeah he actually caught himself there
he got himself there for a minute
yeah go ahead but you know with some
financial [ __ ] like making good
financial moves money moves i'm forever
grateful for everything
i'm gonna say
bro scamming people is not money moves
well it moves money yeah they're gonna
move your ass you know the only moves
you're gonna be making are straight to
prison
beyond the friar for your fiary ferrari
giveaway nelk has worked with wizard to
give out multiple items including a
polaris slingshot do a bunch of fan
meetups a mclaren and more and
originally all of the elk boys were
listed on the partner page uh steve will
do it incidentally is the only only one
still dumb enough to
remain there
here he is with the owner of the website
alfonso
uh go ahead i need to see alfonso's
watch collection so we went to the bank
he got this out was what was this we got
out of the safety deposit box we're
getting the watches we're taking it back
to the safety deposit box as soon as you
show this
[Applause]
this is where it is this is where all
your
this is where all your fans millions of
dollars lost is gone too my friends
this man's why what's the point of okay
i'm not gonna tell a man how to stop how
to spend his stolen money but
i just don't get that why have a
when he says safety deposit box he
probably means at his house not at a
bank right
a safety deposit it's not a bank there's
a very specific thing because like why
are you gonna have a
watch collection and then you gotta like
go to the bank if you want to rock a
watch they flew from the cayman islands
that's where he's uh his bank
is yeah i think you're joking but that's
probably that's right we're gonna find
out in a moment that's probably true
yeah maybe not cayman but one of the
other ones
anyway
go ahead
that 150 quarter million quarter million
quarter million 150 a hundred 129
your [ __ ] greasy fingers off them
another 120 another 60. yeah why you
gotta touch them so hard those are
valuable
over a million right two million
this is straight from alfonso llc to
steve will do it all
yeah you see how little money matters to
this guy it's like
it's awesome because he knows he's gonna
go to jail and look like so he's just
got a full sin before he goes well said
yeah
yeah this guy's going to present for
sure that's dude thanks dog
thanks dog bro i just got a gift
that's a red one that's the scouts
okay come on
kimbo let's go
so i guess that that that's that yeah um
well congratulations to steve will do it
on his new watch
that's cool can i just enter like in all
seriousness those richard mill watches
they're so expensive right now but
they're going and decreasing in value so
they're going to be worth
nothing to in a few years why nothing
they're just they're poorly made and
they're just all hype right now there
you go zach is a as a watch connoisseur
and he is absolutely slammed dunked on
that collection this is zach the
soundland not zach the soundline not the
zac the full send uh bernstein right
bernstein
yes i am a jew but like no but that's
the name of the bears you have the same
name as the bears thank you for teasing
me yes
i'm not trying to tease you it just
struck me as aren't the bears bear it's
baron's oh berenstain okay okay yeah i'm
sorry i meant to say that i used to get
teased for that uh i'm sorry no no no
it's all good tragic hurt his feelings i
mean
is it much of a like what's the insult i
mean it's cool no no it's not it's just
that my elementary school uh what's up
bernstein yeah one of the greatest like
how's the what's the porridge
temperature at
i'm mixing wrong stories yeah all right
moving on with a coffeezilla of course
another great youtuber you guys should
check out as we're doing some deep
investigative work if you want the full
scoop definitely check him out but
coffeezilla looked into the wizard
situation and learned that the owner of
wizza
also owns a sketchy offshore gambling
website
similar to one that we've
covered including like train wreck and
all there's this whole twitch gambling
it's it's own it's the same [ __ ]
also owned in carousel the same place
yeah a hut and carousel right
this is not good no it's not it's really
not
um it is called rubet
which nelk frequently promotes now once
again
they frequently promote this guy's
gambling website the same guy that owns
wizza who's their
best friend
who just casually gave him a 200 000
watch
um the the cast of people promoting this
site is the usual suspects mike
madgelick the
addiction specialist
mike magelick the addiction specialist
who promotes gambling known as the
deadliest vice
to his fans mike magelick
yeah you got it
aiden ross faze blanks etc
the owner was also involved in the cs go
gambling drama so he has deep roots
go ahead please with the video
i'm i know you've been looking into this
who is this alfonso guy or alan whoever
it is all right so i tracked it all down
his name is alan he's a 25 year old
multi-millionaire running the los
angeles social media scene he owns both
rubet and wizard you know roubait right
yeah it's that online casino that steve
will do it and all those guys are
gambling on right there's exactly except
it's offshore unregulated cryptocurrency
based and it's not legal in the u.s and
they are raking in tens of millions of
dollars per month oh my gosh wait a
second you're saying allen owns that
along with whizza as well yep those are
some big accusations how do you know
it's this like frat bro behind it all he
doesn't have his name on it right well
he does have rubet's name on himself
he's quite literally got a tattoo of it
on his wrist which he showcases above
his richard mill you know the five
hundred thousand dollar watch again you
know all the ass just unbelievable it's
like the sticky bandits and home alone
totally sticky grounded [ __ ]
christ
all right should we continue with this
please the one that all the 25 year olds
own yeah yeah i mean i got two of them
but uh i got them also on the transitive
property of aidan ross wait you got what
do you mean you got a clip for that or
something of course let's roll it this
house is sponsored by a company called
like wizards
i haven't paid rent at all but i could
do and if you guys can you guys could
literally help me come up with giveaways
like challenges and like
like last person to blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah like i can literally
promote that [ __ ]
so aiden ross gave away the game once
again these people are too dumb to
possess information incriminating
information aid in the chosen one
so we weren't supposed to know that it's
owned by the same people but adam ross
once again
gave away the game oops um
aiden just pay your own rent you [ __ ] we
know how much money you make just like
i mean dude why you gotta live in a
house they pay for just
come on man
it's so weird go back uh oh is that it
i guess that was it that was it yeah so
go ahead steve will do it responds to
coffeezilla's
accusations here's some tweets
just found out that top gambling
streamers are getting paid a percentage
of their sign ups
losses yeah we knew that actually based
on the the coverage we did about twitch
streamers doing this so not only are
streamers getting paid
millions to promote the gambling to
their fans but they're literally
incentivized for their fans to lose as
much as possible
how did these people sleep at night
coffee asks which is you know a good
question steve responds i sleep very
well at night in my penthouse knowing
that i change people's lives every day
and i'm rich you change people's lives
every day and that's why you're rich you
take their money here he is responding
in video form
about people who who their job they make
money by what by making content about
other people and making content about
other people it's crazy it's crazy i'm
getting hate because we just we just
watched
we just we just watched like
four of my videos and i did and i gave
two single moms fifty thousand dollars
i gave my friend's dad in need fifty to
half thousand dollars i gave my best
friend fifty thousand dollars
i gave my editors parents fifty thousand
dollars
i bought all my friends cars i bought
all these single moms cars
are like 30. i gave a random soldier 30
000 and and i'm watching this in like
that's pretty badass and and then and
then at the end people are surprised
that i make money from gambling
but when i make
i'm really surprised no but i mean
that's like working out his brain you
see his brain is turning hard yeah i
mean listen it's easy to give away 250
000
when you just made a million
scamming people i mean pablo escobar
used to give a lot of charity too and no
you don't seem hear many people singing
his praises it's a common practice that
when you uh you know
basically
plunder
a [ __ ] load of money it's easy pr to
give a small percentage senegitive away
and look like a saint but ultimately
that's all ill-gotten money so sure you
can give it away but you're still a
thief
you know your your mom gets 50 000 which
is great for your mom and you
but uh you basically stole that from a
bunch of your fans
um and much more
i'm just spitting facts you know
absolutely
so we are continuing about rubet
uh here's a clip where one of the elk
boys runs out of cash
while using rubet and literally calls up
his homie one of the owners
to send more funds
this is great and once again
some ordinary gamer mudahar has also
been covering this extensively so if you
guys want more details i'd recommend
checking out his videos too they're all
really good these guys are putting a lot
of work into this so
shout out
um
yeah once again
rubet is the website owned by their best
friends they're promoting go ahead dan
nelk for instance runs out of their
money how do you think they get to get
it back watch this we just lost 15 racks
all right well
let's call howie that was a test
called how we call um not really sure
what happened there you might need to
call how you might even really call
howie off-screen
because that was
so they got a call howie well let's see
what how he's gonna do they just lost 15
racks if you look at their bitcoin
wallet here they're sitting at a toasty
zero dollars okay god damn don't worry
guys how he comes in clutch look at that
bitcoin wallet up top they're back to
plane crash same exact stream that we
were watching god damn
um
damn boys you saw it right there god
damn 15k straight up caught just
credited to the account now again we
looked at kyle's like you know bitcoin
wallet that i guess he showed during
this high stakes gambling you know
extravagant
yeah um that's pretty [ __ ] shady
well
i mean have you ever gone to vegas when
you're down i mean you just asked to see
the pit boss and be like hey man can i
get some more yeah that bet was kind of
saucy yeah yeah no problem
so there you have it i mean this thing
is crooked all the way through
you know
and by the way if they were smart he
would have just deposited the money and
got reimbursed for it afterwards but
because they're so [ __ ] dumb on
stream he goes yo call the owner and
have him transfer the money over they're
so dumb they're dumb they're just
pathetically dumb here's steve on the
same website uh go back please dan
just on on
full screen please
uh here's steve winning seven hundred
thousand dollars and one minute on the
site that is admittedly owned by one of
his best friends while playing in the
united states where by the way rubet is
not allowed
love that just like with the train wreck
thing that's the part that baffles me
almost the most out of all this is like
all these sites are illegal in the us
i mean train wreck ran away to canada so
that he could continue doing it legally
there but like
there
aiden lives in la this guy lives in
miami i mean all these people are in
these no they're they're blatantly
breaking the law on twitter and i
guarantee you the vast majority probably
even in the 90 percentile of their
customers are in the united states i
mean yeah this is where their audience
is yeah and and well what it does for
the company is basically ensures that
they can always
not pay people out because they're in
the us
because you weren't supposed to be
gambling yeah you broke the terms
and it's illegal for us to pay you
you're so right oh for sure yeah
great uh go ahead
right there just like that just like
that
fit yet
50 grand bro the 500 great the 500k
dream is real it's alive
[Laughter]
oh my god let's keep going
oh my god multiplier 100 x 100 x 100 x
100 x hundred x hundred
fifteen fifteen
oh my god 100 x 100 x 50 x 50 x
high level entertainment here are my
parents
you believe other people they just they
make content about other people unlike
me where i just sit in a dark room and
play slot machines for hours on end yeah
i mean as someone who's who basically is
critical of other people i do find that
criticism odd it's like are you
are you saying that like the entire
field of like journalism is documentary
making new york times reporters
entertainment business
biographies right
you know
yeah
but also like am i i mean surely
scrutinizing you is
it's a whole vertical so
there's plenty of content there you've
created for us
now this leads us to one of the most
scandalous
things
a website called private bet a new
gambling website
that the elk boys have started to
promote
and a youtuber named harris
8 9 aiden
uncovered that private bets social media
was using an at shots.com domain
and at shots.com leads to the site of
nelk's management team
along with this they found on the
wayback machine that private bet's
social media handles originally had full
send
in the titles and not long after posting
this
harris ayton's video was taken down and
he received a copyright strike the
strike was issued by timeless inc
however the contact email links directly
back to nelk the in the implications of
course is that
they
saw how lucrative this business was and
they decided well why get paid to
promote someone else's site when we can
just make our own site
and promote that we'll make a lot more
money because the millions isn't enough
and by the way the i would say that the
liability is greatly increased when you
own the site versus when you promote it
so that's a full send moment right there
absolutely go ahead coffeezilla has a
great uh
this video just came out today too so
this is fresh off the press here
apparently for this deal as well and if
that's the case i think they should have
just come forward and addressed this
stuff sooner um but speaking frankly
this kind of thing this giveaway thing
is kind of like a full me once full me
twice situation you know what they say
about that don't you you better not fool
me a third time but of course it gets
worse yeah because right after this
disastrous promotion with whizza and
rubet they literally start promoting
another gambling casino private bet has
a pretty sweet deal for you guys right
now they actually having a hundred
percent deposit bonus guarantee
this is like basically
i mean
scam 101 i mean pro syndicate and t
martin the whole gambling's uh cs go
gambling thing was about them doing
exactly this being like hey i heard
about this great new website that i
totally don't own
right
and and here they are once again not
disclosing
that they apparently own this excuse me
gambling site go ahead
uh all you have to do is use my code
kyle make an account on privatebet.com
and dm him your username and we're going
to give away 250.
250 dollars to a home this isn't my
first road so all you guys on
privatebet.com
250 each privatebet.com we'll be doing
this real life i love how he's like
boxing his now this is totally weird for
a lot of reasons first of all
and obviously nobody's heard of this
website like when you look it up it
looks a little bit like like brand new
and that's basically because it is it's
offshore parent company uh xyz
entertainment as it's called was created
may 25th 2021. this thing's like a
little baby so why promote it i mean why
is a company like nelk not going with an
established casino instead of just like
a brand new one like this and this
immediately got people thinking there's
got to be more to this story and this
got even more damning when some social
media accounts called at blackjack were
found being used for private bat here
they are right here these have been
since privated and the reason they were
private is because they were tied back
by a youtuber named harrison
two people from nelk apparently nelk's
uh president the president of full sint
apparently owns those social media
accounts the obvious implication here
being of course that private bet was
owned or tied to nelk more than
previously known which would obviously
make sense of the reason that they're
promoting this brand new casino this was
further confirmed on the blackjack
facebook page which was previously known
as private bet and before that known as
blackjack ventures and before that known
as fulsoned blackjack now i would show
you some of harrison's video uncovering
all of this but unfortunately
surprise surprise it was copyright
striked by none other than elk now i
contacted milk about this because of
course this seemed extremely fishy and
they told me hey there's been a
misunderstanding they don't own private
bet at all
but they know who does but refused to
say
but apparently they were working out a
marketing deal with private bet and a
social media deal that's the reason
their socials were connected was because
apparently milk owned some gambling
social media accounts at blackjack and
they were going to let them use them in
exchange for a lucrative deal yeah
tell it to the judge
wait that's you
tell it to me guilty
you know um
yeah these guys are scum they're looking
for the easiest and fastest fastest way
to make money
and you've seen how much like adam ross
as an affiliate makes two million
dollars a month you can only imagine how
much they'd be making owning it it's a
shameless cash grab illegal shameless
unethical and absolutely
[ __ ] morally bankrupt disgusting
freak show
and then when people are figuring it out
they're taking down their videos it's uh
heinous
more than just their videos making their
reddit private oh when people started
speculating about the connection on
their subreddit
nelk films they privated the community
to shut down the conversation
and if uh this isn't an isolated
incident another user named tripping who
made a video critical of nelk faced a
copyright strike and had their video
taken down this there have been multiple
other instances of criticism videos of
nelk being taken down by them
so this never happens again you know
right what are the odds that happens to
us
uh they're not gonna say higher than
winning uh a ferrari
non-zero yeah
i mean that would be interesting i don't
think they would have the balls to try
that but i think they don't have a
problem with
smaller youtubers uh uh stomping on them
right because they know they wouldn't
actually be able to do anything about it
uh next slide please thank you
uh that's uh well that brings us to the
end um
extremely shady shameless
predatory
some freak [ __ ] that's a guilty verdict
on all three charges i believe we have
exhausted our evidence we have found
them guilty on all charges
and these dudes really suck what can i
say that's an understatement
was that a triple kill that i just heard
uh yes it was zach or a b you guys want
to add anything in closing here
i think it pretty much said stuff i'm
going to wrap up i do actually want to
thank the discord um and give a special
shout out to avery uh our mod mega
awesome nerd helped us put together
uh this content court thank you guys
very much appreciate you
yeah i got to be saying i'm very
impressed with what we put together on
the discord not only for the level of
research that we did there but also they
kept the lid on this thing man yeah they
did a good job i didn't see anybody leak
who was it about until last night on
reddit right but that's really good
because like i saw people
kept
people were speculating about who's the
content were gonna be about and no there
wasn't anybody like spilling the beans
so
mum's the word shout out to the disc
good opsec
foot soldiers good offset and zach is
there anything you want to say um
in short here
[ __ ] this [ __ ] dude i'm done you're done
huh do you want to admit you bought that
yourself no you're taking off the bass
pro shop hat oh no you're leaving it on
i'm taking off the jacket dude this this
is a sign of shame damn
for sure that's true i mean can you
imagine actually running into someone
wearing full sent merch i mean wow
crystal nelk you know
like pepsi oh crystal knocked yeah
trying to be funny oh yeah that was that
was crystal nuts
it's a logical joke something milk boys
would never get but never mind that it's
interesting the minute you take off the
jacket you're eight your iq raised like
50 points
is it amazing you're dropping crystal
knock jokes
yeah amazing
anyways yeah [ __ ] them they're pieces of
[ __ ] okay okay thank you looks like we
uh convinced their own attorney
powerful stuff
and shout out to everybody in the crew
abe and
specifically uh
anyone else everyone everybody really
worked ian really slammed
yeah you guys really abe took the lead
on it and um everyone worked really hard
to put the
the case together lots of ends lots of
outs as you can imagine so shout out to
his family shout out to the families
and content court is back baby
let's go
shout out to the foot soldiers foot
soldiers waiting for it
yeah
watch out ryan kavanagh you should be
sweating
i feel like we content court him every
week
yeah the only thing protecting is that
nobody cares about him
yeah
anyway hope you guys enjoyed
this court is now out of session
if you could please make everyone rise
for me as i exit the court uh rise for
the honorable judge ethan as he exits
the court as he just said just
reiterating that
thank you good work everyone
[Music]
have sunder
[Music]
all right